that's an exciting entrance
thank you very much thank you you came
out here and you just took control
i care i don't care i don't care i don't
care
yeah i don't know what the rest of the
words are it doesn't matter i guess
that was incredible you look uh you look
fantastic thank you i haven't seen you
in a little while uh you man this is
look at your
your hair it's gotten uh very long let
it go a little bit yeah
is this for a part that you grew it out
like that no but there's a part in it
you know i always make sure that there's
a part in mine very nice very nicely
done yeah i just i just felt like
growing it out you know feeling free is
the breeze you know
i just love it i love it i love i love
long hair
you know
[Music]
give me it down to that hair shoulder
length
[Applause]
[Music]
wow you were going to hold that for a
long time if i didn't get you out of it
it would have been there forever
yeah london time warp that was uh that
was incredible not many guests do that
out of nowhere yeah you've always wanted
to do that
yeah just worked it out with the band
before coming out
someone should tell me uh well no it's
very good to have you on the show
it's really always fun talking to you
and you know it's interesting
i think people have this perception of
you as just being the you know funny
crazy guy
they know me yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly and then you snap at them like
that and then they get scared
exactly no but you know it's funny they
try to feed me yeah dancing
next thing you know i'm up in the car
breaking the window yeah but you know
you're you're deeper than that like i
know you're into a lot of reading
what are you reading these days what are
you studying what are you reading i
absolutely love
reading i love i'm a huge reader and
when i pick up something i just can't
put it down you know
like quantum physics that's my favorite
quantum physics
like what are you talking about
quantifies like what i was just reading
this uh incredible paper on the
stochastic phase shifting of a
parametrical driven
electron and a penning trap and
apparently
a bistability arises dynamically in this
specific
parametrically driven systems because
the phase psi
of the electron's steady state
oscillation can either have
the two values separated by pi yeah
that's that's crazy you know you that
was amazing you know you shot
okay that's great that was incredible
because you know it's funny what shocks
me about an electron in a penny trap is
that most amplitude collapses are
accompanied by a phase flip
given that the rate of escape from an
attractor depends exponentially upon an
activation energy e is the diffusion
constant d
approaches t sub n and rho approaches
epsilon
to the negative e over d absolutely yeah
absolutely
no question we talked about this of
course
i i don't know about that conan uh have
you considered that the parametric
driving force excites a nearly
resonant electron oscillation at the
drive frequency omega sub d over three
equals omega sub z plus
epsilon it's a classic example of the
period doubling that occurs when a
linear oscillator is strongly driven
max did you just say that the omega sub
d
over three equals omega sub z plus
epsilon
yeah whoa
it's actually omega sub d over two
equals omega sub z
plus epsilon wow wow max
max you know nothing about quantum
physics
you're right yes
it's lonely over here it is all right
we're going to take a break we have a
lot to talk about we haven't scratched
the surface more with jim carrey when we
come back stick around